[Music]
another celebrity revealed on the mast
singer the reason I did this actually is
because people have a tendency to
prejudge you and the way you sing and
the things do they compare you to other
people in your family and I just want to
do it and see how far I go when you saw
the reveal with her what did you think
that was definitely a for me it was a
surprise yeah for everybody there was
like an elegance to the way she would
move and sing so oh this may be a model
turned singer or a model who can't sing
credit her himself you know for really
kind of you know kind of disguising her
Vil you know disguising her voice
the competition is well underway Latoya
is the latest singing celebrity in
disguise to get the boot following Ricki
Lake it seems like it was a wild ride it
was a wild ride it was a journey for me
and it was very cathartic you know you
and I were talking off-camera about you
know might the loss of my husband it
really helped me in honoring him and
Tori Spelling you trusted your children
to not share this on the playground at
school the reason I did it is four of
them and I wanted them involved in the
process I wanted them to know how scary
this was yet empowering at the same time
buckle your seatbelts because the masked
singer confirmed they're coming back for
season two et recently spoke with the
panelists about the exciting news it is
a gift that keeps on giving it is like
it it's so much fun to be on that show
and so chuffed and over-the-moon that
the show is so well received because we
never expected this this success we
always hoped it would be but it exceeded
our expectations obviously I really had
intuition of this working but when I try
to explain it to people before it aired
they looked at me like I was nuts and
now that it's aired everyone you know
you love the masked singer how many of
your slug friends are now texting you
being like um I'd love to be a part of
the show that's a good question have you
here to share any names worthy they're
your friends you're like you're like
nothing not it's not good enough we're
just riding the wave right now it's
all--it's Point Break time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]